[Music]
tomorrow morning former amazon ceo jeff
bezos will bless blast off rather to the
edge of space in his own spaceship
now this will be a landmark moment for
blue origin that's his space company and
for van horn texas
that's the closest town to where this
space drama will play out
mark straussman joins us once again from
van horn with more on the tiny community
that everybody will be watching tomorrow
so mark the question
for me i'm wondering how tiny is tiny
good morning good morning gail
you're about to see just how tiny it is
i mean let's face it when you think
about space in texas you think about
houston
and as you can tell this part of the
state it's a long way from houston van
horn
sits about 120 miles east of el paso
it's small
unremarkable and a bit bewildered by its
own launch into the space spotlight
[Applause]
van horn west texas typically known as a
tank of gas and a bathroom break
a pit stop for i-10 travelers some who
grab a bite
at lisa cottrell's restaurant before
moving on
to the next dot of humanity about 100
miles
any direction for anyone or anything
pretty much
van horn has a couple thousand people
tops
we drove in on the main draft this
broadway
has no neon lights it's lighted
intersection
the only one in all of culberson county
3 800 square miles
yet the richest guy on the planet came
here
to colonize the cosmos the my town part
of it
is the thing that's the most
unbelievable
becky brewster knows all about blue
origin's local impact
she ought to she's van horn's mayor i
don't think we've ever had anything
quite this big
this just kind of fell in your lap yes
it definitely fell in our lap
more like walked into larry simpson's
office in 2005
he owned and published the weekly paper
the van horn advocate
circulation 1500 came through the front
door
jeff bezos in the flesh with a story
idea
bezos quietly had been buying out local
ranchers
by one estimate assembling roughly 300
000 acres in all he started filling me
in on
why he was buying ranch land why he
wanted it for his
kids and then we got around that he
wanted it also to build spaceport
he buried the lead yeah yeah would you
think yourself
really in van horn texas i immediately
said
this could put van horn on the map that
front page news stunned van horn
and beyond for one day the van horn
advocate had
the biggest headline in the space world
in the space world yes sir
lisa cottrell remembers thinking come on
well i think anybody's first reaction
would be
okay we'll see how far that goes
becky brewster what went through your
mind oh how cool
exactly i mean i watched star
trek and star wars so this this was just
cool over time bezos became
the face of space in van horn
25 miles north of the city blue origin
built a spaceport
275 company employees work here
rockets launched tuesday morning
one of them will carry bezos himself to
space
with three other passengers hello thank
you for calling hotel capitan
van horn has a star date with history
we are completely booked hotel el
capitan's 50 rooms
sold out months ago for the launch and
then this is going to be the jubilee
starvana cottrell hometown girl
great name is the general manager we're
nervous
i'm nervous i don't know who's coming
like there's going to just be random
people flooding in here i don't know
what we're going to do with them but i'm
super excited about what's going to
happen but it's a little scary
what do you hope the town gets out of
this well i hope that
people now recognize you know who we are
on the map and know that
we're so much more than just the
tumbleweed town
sheriff oscar carrillo and his entire
force 10 deputies
hope they have a plan for crowd control
he warns
most spectators won't see much texas
highway
54 which runs to the spaceport will
close
for 12 miles as van horn readies
to reach for the stars you haven't
rented a room you're not going to get
one
if you haven't read an rv spot you're
not going to find one big expectation to
see
jeff bezos walking down our highways
you're not going to see it the closest
thing is going to be a mural across the
street
so take a lot of pictures
van horn feels a little overwhelmed
there are only a handful of restaurants
for instance
and hundreds of space fans could be
showing up so all in all i think
people are both excited and a little bit
nervous about tomorrow's big moment
probably a little bit like
jeff bezos and his three fellow
passengers
or anthony or jeff bezos as they call
him in van horn
which is surely on the map now thank you
mark and be sure to tune
in to cbs news tomorrow morning for
special coverage of the launch
and landing of the blue origin
spacecraft gail will lead our coverage
from texas that's tomorrow morning at 9
00 a.m
eastern time 6 pacific and there's more
space coverage on today's cbs this
morning podcast
mark discusses the billionaire space
race with cbs news space contributor
bill harwood we'll be right
back